Понад 200 мільйонів людей у світі інфікувалися коронавірусом.
Останнім часом кількість заражень знову зростає -  через дельта-варіант.
Водночас менше людей хочуть вакцинуватись,
адже подейкують, що вакцини неефективні проти цього варіанту.
Однак чи правда це? Щоб перевірити це твердження,
ми звернулися до університетської клініки Бонна.
Це одна з найбільших лікарень Німеччини. Ми поговоримо з провідними медиками,
аби з'ясувати, як дельта-варіант впливає на зараження.
Лікар Єнс-Крістіан Шеве працює у відділенні інтенсивної терапії.
Каже, серед тих, кого ушпиталюють із дельта-варіантом,
дуже мало хто повністю вакцинований.
Якщо зважати, що 99% пацієнтів з важким перебігом,
яких ми лікували в Бонні, не були щеплені,  тоді, звісно, можна зробити висновок,
що вакцинація дійсно захищає принаймні від важкого перебігу хвороби.
Та чи захищає вакцинація від дельта-варіанту?
Ось що стверджують люди у соцмережах:
Можна зіпсувати комусь день трьома словами
Вакцина не працює
Твердження: Дехто каже, що вакцини від коронавірусу узагалі не працюють.
Висновок: Неправда
Найактуальніша статистика свідчить, що 97% заражень коронавірусом у Німеччині
нині припадає на дельта-варіант.
Кількість госпіталізацій із цим варіантом вища, ніж з початковим.
Твердження: Вакцини від коронавірусу дають 100% захист від дельта-варіанту
Висновок: Неправда
Згідно з висновками експертів і науковими доказами,
є три основні причини, чому деякі повністю вакциновані люди
все ще ризикують серйозно захворіти або померти від дельта-варіанту.
Якщо брати до уваги ефективність вакцин, очевидно, що жодна з них не дає
100-відсоткового захисту від COVID-19.
Сум’я Свамінатан очолює команду науковців
Всесвітньої організації охорони здоров’я.
Вона каже, що усі вакцини допомагають захиститися від дельти.
Усі вакцини захищають від зараження -
різною мірою залежно від вакцини.
Але що дійсно важливо,
що всі вони захищають від важкого перебігу хвороби.
Одна з причин низької ефективності вакцин -
слабка імунна відповідь деяких людей.
Імунна відповідь у різних людей - різна,
і на неї впливає низка факторів.
Так, вік - один з таких факторів,
адже імунна відповідь зовсім маленьких дітей і людей дуже похилого віку
зазвичай слабша, ніж у здорових дорослих.
Хронічні хвороби та інші фактори теж можуть впливати на імунну відповідь.
Друга причина - на ефективність вакцини можуть впливають певні ліки,
що їх приймає людина.
Люди, які приймають так звані імуносупресори
або мають трансплантовані органи, не дуже добре реагують на вакцини.
Попри високу ефективність дозволених вакцин,
експерти вважають, з часом їхня дія зменшується.
Тож це третя причина.
Ефективність вакцини з часом знижується.
І деякі люди за нещасливих обставин все ж можуть серйозно захворіти.
Твердження: Визнані вакцини від ковіду не забезпечують достатнього захисту проти дельта-варіанту
Висновок: Неправда
Найкращий спосіб уникнути ушпиталення або навіть смерті
від дельта-варіанту - повністю щепитися.
Рівень ефективності вакцин різниться у клінічних дослідженнях
та при практичному застосуванні у різних країнах.
Дані щодо допущених у ЄС препаратів свідчать:
ці вакцини надають дуже високий ступінь захисту.
За даними дослідження з Канади,
ефективність препарату BioNTech/Pfizer проти зараження дельта-варіантом
становить 56% після першої дози щеплення,
і 87% після повноцінної вакцинації.
Згідно з тим же дослідженням, Модерна надає 72-відсотковий захист
від зараження коронавірусом уже після першої дози.
А ось повноцінних даних щодо захисту після двох доз –немає.
Дослідження у Британії показало, що щеплення препаратом AstraZeneca
надає захист у 71% після першої дози і 92% - після другої.
Компанія Johnson & Johnson стверджує, що її вакцина генерує
потужну імунну відповідь. Утім, конкретних цифр,
як і незалежних даних щодо препарату - немає.
Усі опитані DW експерти переконані, що вакцини
ефективно захищають від дельта-варіанту.
Вакцинація - ефективний інструмент,
але не єдиний, щоб контролювати цю інфекцію.
Варто й надалі дотримуватись заходів індивідуального захисту ще деякий час.
Ці перші результати досліджень засвідчують, що дельта-варіант
є більш резистентним до вакцин, однак повноцінна вакцинація
все ще забезпечує потужний захист від дельти.
Чи зустрічали ви дезінформацію щодо коронавірусу
або вакцин, яку нам варто було б перевірити?
Повідомте нам у коментарях або напишіть на factchecking@dw.com